in 2001 I was asked to make a film about
a community of plantation workers oil
palm plantation workers living on the
outskirts of living about 60 miles
actually from the city of Maiden where I
made the act of killing and they were
struggling to organize a union and I was
asked to make a film documenting their
struggle to organize a union in a place
where unions had been illegal until just
just previously until the fall of the
Suharto dictatorship this was three
years afterwards
it turned out that the biggest that they
desperately needed a union because the
women workers were spraying a herbicide
that was destroying their livers and
killing them and they were they knee and
they were working for a big Belgian
plantation company and they needed to be
able to to have a union so they wouldn't
have to poison themselves and it turned
out their largest their biggest obstacle
in organizing a union was fear fear
because their parents grandparents aunts
uncles had been in a union and had been
accused in 1965 of being communist
sympathizers just because they had been
in a union had been put in concentration
camps by the army and then dispatched by
the army to death squads to be killed
and they were afraid that having a new
union this could happen again
at the same time they desperately needed
a union and as we started talking about
the source of that fear namely the 65
genocide the mass killings they started
to send me on these really painful these
painful missions if you like I was asked
to go and meet neighbors in the village
whom they who they knew had been somehow
involved with the killings and hoped
would have information about how their
loved ones had died because their
relatives had been taken away and then
disappeared never came back and they
were they had never really been able to
grieve or mourn what had happened
because they didn't actually know what
it that they didn't have proof and that
their relatives had died and they didn't
have the closure that comes with proof
and so I would go on these missions and
meet the perpetrators and find men who
were
with you I was circumspect in my
approach I would arrive and I'd say what
did you do I just introduced myself as
someone living in the village they would
be curious who's the foreigner in the
village they'd invite me in offer me tea
typically they would within moments of
asking what did you do for a living they
would start they would tell me about the
killings and they would boast about it I
think I think this was because somehow
the killings were the biggest thing they
had done and the key to whatever career
they had afterwards all of the the human
rights advocates with whom we met said
no this is terribly important you're
onto something terribly important they
saw the boastful footage that I'd shot
with these few perpetrators who had been
sent to meet they said this is so
important we need a film that exposes
for Indonesians themselves the nature of
this regime not because Indonesians
don't know it but rather because they
know it and are too afraid to talk about
it so they need a film that works a
little bit like the child in the
Emperor's New Clothes that allows people
to talk about what they've been too
afraid to talk about and address
problems they know are there but have
been too afraid to address so one of the
survivors said you know if it's too
difficult to film with the survivors if
we're too vulnerable
it's too dangerous why don't you feel
more perpetrators because you're finding
out what happened and when viewers see
the nature of their both when they see
them boasting they'll understand why
we're so afraid and they'll understand
the nature of the regime we're living
under so from that point which was the
beginning of 2004 I went and filmed
every really every perpetrator I could
find across the plantation belt of North
Sumatra I felt compelled to film them
because I knew they knew what happened
we're talking about the murders of tens
of thousands perhaps hundreds of
thousands of people and nope as these
men were growing old and as they would
die the facts of what had happened would
be lost and Anwar was the 41st
perpetrator I met and when I met him I
expected really and filmed and I
expected really to combine make a film
with a great many of these perpetrators
I met from across the region but there
was something haunted about Anwar in the
sense that when he told me on that
rooftop the very first time I met him
when he told me what he had done there
was this sense that the
past was present unlike many of the
perpetrators would sort of mechanically
or boastfully tell me what he'd done he
was I couldn't I could picture it he was
haunted he was shadowed by the past the
past was there it was devastating I I
remember dropping him off the very first
time I filmed him at home and just
breaking down in the car on the way home
and by then I'd film dozens of these
guys but I was really affected by him
yeah I think there's a sense of anger
among young people that we've been lied
to in school because they are lied to
the story justifying the killing is
what's told there's a sense of demanding
that the government launch an official
apology and then truth a truth
commission a reconciliation process and
Tribunal's it's much harder to oppress
people who are not afraid and the film
has made it's opened a space for people
to talk about the problems of the
present because that's something I'd
also emphasize the act of killing is a
film about now Anwar there's two musical
numbers in the film one of them is in
the film one of them we don't see the
one that's in the film is born free and
the other was to be a rendition of a
Noirs very favorite song which is Peggy
Lee's is bad all dairies it's a song
about disappointment if you think of it
is that all there is to a circus is that
all there is to falling in love and
anwar re-recorded that song and replaced
the verses in the song with the spoken
verses with anecdotes from his life is
that all there is to killing is that all
there is to starring in a movie and and
when we were looking for a location for
it we were driving along with this row
there's winding mountain road and turn a
bend and then there on a mountain it's
out on the mountainside was this forest
or a goldfish and if you filmmakers
you'll know at that moment you pull over
and ask yourself what is that and what
can we do with that and Anwar said
immediately that's so sad it's so
disappointing it was once a beautiful
creation and now it's decayed weathered
witnessing the world go by and we should
make that our we should that's the
perfect place for this scene here's this
goldfish this product of human fantasy
sitting there exists
persisting not going away witnessing the
ongoing human folly and we see these men
lost in their fantasies it's an allegory
for me of how we all get lost in our
stories how we all create our reality
through storytelling and use
storytelling to run away from our most
bitter and painful truths the lake
behind them is the single most important
spot in our history as a species that is
lake toba it's a crater lake it erupted
as a volcano it was a super volcano that
erupted 50,000 years ago and by that
point human beings Homo sapiens had
already been on earth for earth for nine
hundred fifty thousand years more or
less and there were millions of us and
we were all over the planet and we were
at this that the volcanic winter caused
by the eruption of this supervolcano was
so severe that it killed all of us apart
from a band of somewhere between one and
ten thousand people living in isolation
somewhere in the world and the way we
know this is that a geneticist can look
at everybody in Manhattan and see that
we all have only fifty thousand years of
evolutionary divergence between us that
we all have evolved from a single group
isolated group 50,000 years ago and when
geologists look at what could have
caused this mask what's called an
evolutionary bottleneck we went through
a bottleneck it could only have been the
Toba supervolcano so that's called the
Toba bottleneck it's the Toba super
catastrophe and in that sense in a very
real sense in the final shot there they
are dancing a dance macabre at the very
edge of the abyss